[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le coach bout et myriam smir est sont de
retour avec nous pour répondre à
quelques-unes des très nombreuses
questions que nous avons reçu tout au
cours de la journée meriem lucre bonsoir
bonsoir première question pour myriam
j'ai eu 60 71 ans en mars 2021 nous dit
daniel des chéneaux est ce que est ce
que je devrais remplir ma déclaration
pour 2021 différemment de celle des
années précédentes mairie hier sont déjà
convertis en effet revu en faire depuis
quelques années je fractionne mes
revenus de pension avec mon conjoint qui
avait 64 ans à 21 en 2021 qu'en
pensez-vous myriam en fait rien
limitation effectivement qui existent au
niveau du fractionnement de revenu pour
l'âge de 65 ans mais pour l'âge de 65
ans elle existe seulement pour le
pensionnat qui fractionnent sont revenus
donc étant donné qu'on est un point 65
ans mais bien 71 donc strictement aucune
différence pour pour la déclaration
actuellement pour madame d chez nous
donc à va continuer à fractionner sont
revenus c'est davantage en fait le
conjoint qui a pas 65 ans qui ne peut
pas de son côté fractionné quoi que ce
soit qui doit attendre d'atteindre 65
ans surtout qu'au québec on ne peut pas
frattini le revenu six ans après 65
effectivement ok deuxième question de se
l'acheter pour lui que j'ai 63 3 ans je
travaille depuis plusieurs années est ce
que j'ai droit au crédit d'impôt pour
prolongation de carrière clair je
travaille dans une entreprise familiale
si la question c'est vraiment entreprise
familiale donc la réponse courte c'est
non ce qu'il faut comprendre on voudrait
pas qu'un salarié qui soit lui-même un
actionnaire dirigeants puissent se
verser de salaire pour avoir trop crédit
donc que ce soit sa propre entreprise
l'entreprise de son mari l'entreprise de
son frère ou sa soeur de ses enfants si
un lien de dépendance le crédit le
salaire n'est pas admissible au crédit
prolongation de carrière ok parfait
réponse claire myriam à votre tour une
question de raymond baril qui dit j'ai
déjà reçu l'avis de cotisation avant le
rabais de 500 $ il parle du crédit de
500 $ et site du gouvernement du québec
je dois payer un montant de plus de 1000
$ en impôts est ce que je vais recevoir
un autre avis soustrait de 500 $ ou je
soustrais moi même ce montant en fait le
revenu québec a déjà annoncé que si
l'avis de cotisation avait déjà été
envoyé il ya un ajustement qui allait se
faire et si un remboursement il se
réfugie famille donc dans le cas de
monsieur barry lui pourrait simplement
payer là le montant du moins de 500
dollars étant donné qu'il va y avoir une
autre avis de cotisation qui va et et me
dit si la famille mais comme lui que
nous disait en début d'émission ont pu
aussi rien faire le gouvernement va
s'occuper de votre 500 c'est ça
effectivement mais il faut pas oublier
qu'il faut par contre payer le solde dû
avant le 2 mai pour éviter des intérêts
donc pour simplifier si on ne veut pas
payer la totalité ans devrait payer le
solde du moins de 500 dollars le 500 $
sera pris en charge par une deuxième
avis de cotisation qui ont été mis par
le gouvernement effectivement lu qu
est-ce qu on peut bénéficier cette année
d'un report pour payer un solde du eric
labonté dieu eu des rapports dans à
cause de la pandémie c'était une mesure
exceptionnelle les choses
exceptionnelles n'arrive pas tous les
ânes et donc non cette année il n'y a
pas de report qui de prévu la date
limite pour produire sa déclaration
techniquement c'est le 30 avril mais
comme le 30 avril et 1 samedi nous avons
donc jusqu'au 2 mai pour produire et
aucun autre délai n'a été annoncée
parfait autre question pour myriam je me
suis séparée de mon ex conjoint en
décembre 2021 la déclaration de 2021 et
donc toucher nous avons deux enfants qui
sont maintenant garde partagée quels
sont les éléments importants à
considérer dans la déclaration de
revenus demande julien dubé
effectivement les déclarations de 2021
vont être touchés dont il ya plusieurs
éléments il va y avoir le fait qu'on
doit faire une déclaration distingue
donc chacun des deux contribuables ou
des deux ex conjoints doit faire sa
propre déclaration et non reporter leurs
revenus de l'eau est également c'est que
dans la déclaration de chacun est
endémique scène garde partagée chaque
chacun des deux conjoints pour reprendre
est des enfants à charge donc quand on a
deux enfants c'est plus facile chacun
prend un enfant à charge et ça nous
permet d'aller chercher un crédit
supplémentaire de points comme personne
à charge est également il faut se
rappeler que les frais médicaux c'est
les personnes qu'ils à payer qui peut
les réclamer il ya également des règles
ans a plutôt au niveau des frais de
garde car les freegans doivent être
réclamés par les personnes qu'ils
appuyaient mais il faut que l'enfant
était avec la personne donc étant donné
qu'ils étaient déjà en copie peuvent
diviser moitié moitié mais par la suite
ça on est dans une séparation de sur
toute l'année faut vraiment que ce soit
les frais bio at on appris pendant qu'on
avait la responsabilité c'est en vue
dans l'enfant yao d'autres éléments
aussi c'est que les allocations
familiales vont être impactés mais ça ça
devient quelqu'un qui soit un peu plus
tard que dans la déclaration étant donné
qu'on voit pas prendre le revenu
familial mais leurs revenus de chacun
des deux contribuables et la location
formule ait visé par deux étant donné
que c'est un des deux conjoints de les
deux contribuent atlas est en train de
me dire que fiscalement c'est possible
quand on sait par au pas du tout aucun
du tout
parfait
question suivante maintenant linke yade
qui dit je vis seule je suis
propriétaire j'ai 64 ans je suis en
arrêt de travail mon fils qui est
majeure habite avec moi puis je mettre
personne vivant seule car je ne reçois
aucun revenu de loyer plus qu la notion
de recevoir ou non un loyer nantes pas
dans la logique ici du de l'aveu du
montant pour personnes vivant seules
pour avoir droit au montant pour
personnes vivant seules il faut
effectivement vivre seul toute l'année
il y à quelques exceptions si on vit
avec un enfant mineur on peut quand même
avoir droit pour montant pour personnes
vivant seules six ont avec un enfant
majeur qui va aux études à plein temps
ou un petit enfant qui vaut aux études à
plein temps on va également conserver le
montant personnes vivant seules donc
pour l'admission en question le seul
moyen d'avoir droit aux montants
personnes vivant seules il faudrait que
son fils majeur soit aux études à plein
temps sinon il n'y aura pas droit
parfait myriam une rétro pour équité
salariale reçu plus de trois ans après
un décès étaient imposables au fédéral
sinon que faire pour récupérer les
sommes déduites à la source demande
mario simon alors on n'est que rarement
capable de dire qu'un montant qui n'est
pas imposable toutes les questions qu'on
reçoit mais effectivement une rétro pour
équité salariale qui a été déterminé
c'est pas juste une notion de payer
sinon notion de déterminer d'un côté ce
que la date quand est-ce qu'on a une
entente en fait pour déterminer montant
de rétro si cette date est arrivé après
la date du décès donc je comprends que
là ça fait 3 1 à ce moment là le montant
n'est pas imposable est donc à ce moment
là ni dans les médias du bénéficiaire ni
dans les mains de la personne décider et
si la date est déterminé après le décès
ce n'est pas un beau âmes et si elle est
déterminée avant le décès s'est imposée
exactement avec imposables comme un
revenu gagné par la personne décédée ici
on a en fait les règles de déduction à
la source les suivent les mêmes règles
que ce que j'ai une dire donc si il ya
une erreur de la part de l'employeur on
peut effectivement aller faire une
déclaration pour se faire rembourser
mais si le il faut vraiment se
regarder la date de détermination de la
rétro pour définir si cet axe abouba
dernière question céline bélanger dit
comment ce calcul le partage du
fractionnement de revenus de pension
pour des retraités l'udc ici quand même
une réponse un peu plus longue mais
c'est une question pertinente parce que
dans les 45 secondes beaucoup d'années
qui s'y intéresse d'abord le
fractionnement lié fictifs il ya pas
vraiment de transfert d'argent entre les
conjoints mais la facture d'impôt elles
les peaux fictive et il ya vraiment des
impôts à payer pour le coup peut-être
inférieur mais payés différemment que
les conjoints c'est pour ça qu'on
demande aux deux conjoints de signer un
formulaire relatif à ce choix-là de
fractionné ou non qu'est ce qui rentre
dans le fractionnement certains revenus
de pension qui sont admissibles les
rejoint les régimes de pension agréés
les sommes d'un fer d'henri heures ça va
être admissible ce qui n'est pas
admissible et des prestations publiques
passion de sécurité de la vieillesse
régime des rentes ça sera pas admissible
et il reste la question de large
généralement c'est au-dessus de 65 ans
65 ans ou plus mais où fédéral lorsque
ces des revenus de pension de type
régimes de pension agréés
on peut le faire sans égard à l'âge donc
dès lors qu'on est revenu de pension
agréés on peut le transférer en
fractionné une partie de son action
conjointe sans égard à l'argent je
rappelle aussi le maximum c'est 50%
qu'on peut transférer de nos revenus de
pension admissible le goût de booster
clair merci beaucoup myriam smir s merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit